bonsoir virginie martin merci de
répondre à nos questions de ce soir sur
rtl france le gouvernement de jean
castex est donc enfin au complet après
la nomination de son secrétaire d'état
jean castex nommé en souvenir avait été
nommé le vendredi 3 juillet
on n 26 pourquoi une si longue attente
une si longue attente parce que toujours
évidemment les dosages sont très précis
ils sont méticuleux forcément mais aussi
évidemment une si longue date ont
certainement aussi un peu politique
politicienne si je puis dire ça permet
aussi de faire croire à celle ceci ou
cela qu'ils vont bientôt être évidemment
qu'ils vont bientôt être être être nommé
et du coup forcément ça peut marcher
plutôt pas mal dans dans l'attenté et le
suspense cinq ex du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe reste parmi eux il ya
c'est vrai qu'au chargé du numérique et
laurent pietra chef qu'il le monsieur
retraites
ça veut dire quoi qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement sur ces dossiers là en ce qui
les concerne
sur ces dossiers je crois que vous avez
vraiment réseau il n'y aura pas
tellement de changements même si on sait
un les syndicats plaident beaucoup 1
pour justement qu'on se calme sur la
question des retraites et de la réforme
les syndicats de cadres ou si le medef
mais là on peut penser qu'il n'y aura
pas de véritable changement je suis
assez d'accord avec vous là dessus si
nouvelle personnalité un également qui
font leur entrée
une parité qui respecte et 21 hommes 22
femmes à voir de nouveaux visages c'est
quoi c'est une opération de
communication ou c'est une réelle
volonté de changement
alors c'est plutôt je dirais si vous
voulez une consolidation de
l'anachronisme c'est très important
c'est une consolidation vraiment du
noyau dur de l'anachronisme
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
monsieur bonne qui est vraiment chère
pas d' emmanuel macron et qu'ils passent
aux affaires européennes donc ça c'est
quelque chose de très important
on consolide à la fois les fidèles
finalement de la république en marche et
on va consolider aussi du côté du modem
qui ont été qu'un un peu les parents
pauvres le modem de la première vague
avait
que les ministres qui ont été nommés
comme vous le disiez le début juillet
alors parmi les nouveaux vous venez de
parler de clément bonne on va le voir à
l'image d'ici quelques instants on voit
sarah la guérilla un porte parle du
modem tellement bonne présenté comme le
monsieur europe d'emmanuel macron après
l'accord au forceps 1 et sur le plan de
relance européens critiqués par le
parlement européen d'ailleurs qui menace
d'entraver le texte à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre sur le dossier de
l'europe a en tout cas
symboliquement c'est important c'est
important puisque finalement aujourd'hui
on pourrait avoir un triangle dans la
politique d' emmanuel macron qui est pas
toujours très clairement lisible pour
tous
on peut avoir un premier tir triant qui
a toujours été un peu ça bah c'est
effectivement l'europe et la nomination
de clément bonne à ce poste-là est très
importante
après il ya peut-être une deuxième
inflexion évidemment avec ce qu'on a vu
des ministres c'est une infection non
plus un maquereau juppé mais un mac
rangs sarkozystes d'accord ça c'est
important avec darmana évidemment le
premier ministre castex et et j'en passe
donc ça c'est important
-la troisième peut-être branches de ce
triangle qui serait certainement les
touches ici moula liés à l'environnement
la biodiversité notamment bégin
dérangeait rabat et il ya quelques
semaines donc la nomination de barbara
pompili pour répondre aussi à vocation
sur l'europe le dossier est important
puisque on a vu que cet accord européen
n'était pas aussi jolie que ce que
emmanuel macron est venu nous le
présenter sur les plateaux de tf1 en
début de semaine il reste six cents
jours un pour la fin de quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron en 600 jours eric
dupond moretti
ministre de la justice a dit qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire de miracle du côté de
la place vendôme
cette question en 600 joueurs que
peuvent faire ces nouveaux secrétaires
d'état
écoutez on s'y sent jours on peut faire
quand même beaucoup de choses
il est compliqué aujourd'hui que la
politique soit sans cesse comme ça
chronométrés dans une urgence
perpétuelle quand c'est pas l'urgence
politiques allemands se sont l'urgence
lié finalement autant médiatique et ça
je trouve que c'est dommageable parce
que tout le monde y perd parce que le
politique peut absolument accélérer
accélérer et souvent souvent du coup
comment est-ce qu'ils accélèrent et bien
il accélère en devenant une démocratie
sondagière une démocratie médiatique une
démocratie d'opinion voir une démocratie
électorale
donc ça c'est très dérangeant parce que
là forcément après on va regarder les
sondages d'opinion comme le faisait dans
les années 90 peut être le premier
michel rocard on va regarder les
sondages d'opinion et on va gouverner au
gré des sondages d'opinion et ça c'est
très dommage on a vu à l'inflexion
sécuritaire très très forte
là actuellement avec permanent d'un côté
castex de l'autre la phraséologie très
très sécuritaires et identitaires dans
les pires moments si je puis dire
sécuritaire de nicolas sarkozy
et là on voit que ça correspond aussi à
une demande finalement de la population
donc ces démocraties sondagière qui sont
sous le feu du temps médiatique et du
temps politique sont quand même assez
dommageable aussi il faut faire
attention à cela
virginie martin je me permets de faire
le calcul 1,16 ministre quatorze
ministres délégués 12 secrétaires d'état
dont un porte parole au total ça fait
quarante deux membres du gouvernement
est ce que c'est beaucoup est-ce que
c'est pas beaucoup quand on sait qu'une
partie de l'opinion publique souhaite
réduire la voilure en terme de budget au
niveau du fonctionnement de l'état
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre de 17 à
ministre aux membres du gouvernement
écoutez vous savez on s'attendait à plus
de 20 secrétaires d'état on en a à peu
près la moitié est finalement ce n'est
pas si mal vous savez sur le train de
vie de l'état quand on l'appelle c'est
peut-être moins le nombre de postes qui
compte en définitive que ce train de vie
souvent délirant où on va refaire qui
les salons de l'elysée qui le fort de
brégançon où on a aussi des anciens
présidents de la république qui coûte
environ 1 2 million d'euros par an vous
voyez c'est tout cela aussi bien c'est
cette république dispense yeuse qui a eu
longtemps l'habitude vivre sous les ors
de la république ceux du sénat ce une
assemblée nationale ce n'est pas laid et
ça c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et
c'est cela peut-être le pire parce que
si les secrétaires d'état et les
ministres travaillent et surtout à faire
dans l'intérêt général et pas dans les
intérêts particuliers
les français et les françaises
comprennent très bien qu'il ya besoin de
monde pour faire un monde avancer la
machine france et c'est normal encore
une question virginie martin au final
quand on voit ce et ses onze secrétaire
d'état nommée aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'il faut en conclure d'une manière
globale d'une manière générale qu'est ce
que quelle est votre analyse d'abord
comme je disais peut-être tout à l'heure
il ya eu une triangulation à droite
pouvoir très à droite avec les discours
de castex darmanin et puis aussi le côté
très anti féministe et ça ça marque
aussi un ce sont des marqueurs très à
droite
et puis comme je le disais aussi
quelques comme ça soupçon de
biodiversité d'écologie de questions
environnementales qu'il faut aujourd'hui
prendre en compte forcément l'europe
très important n'oublions pas après de
manière plus politiciennes que là il ya
une vraie consolidation de la macro ni
vous savez que la république en marche a
perdu sa majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale donc vraiment ça se délite au
niveau de la république en marche les
municipales ont été absolument
catastrophique une vraie des résines à
électorale donc là il faut vraiment
resserrer les rangs compter les fidèles
on voit bien qu'ils ne sont pas si
nombreux
souvent le banc de touche est assez vide
lors le voit et on se resserre on serre
les coudes et on essaye d'aller en ordre
de bataille vers cette présidentielle
c'est forcément cela consolidé est en
même temps trianguler que du côté de la
droite
merci virginie martin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue professeur chercheur à 4
business school et coprésidente du
conseil scientifique de la revue
politique et parlementaire